[موسيقى]
خلف هذه الرسومات بالفحم تكمن قصه عمرها
20 الف سنه تعيد هذه الانامل ابداعها ومن
ثم تسليط الضوء على فن ما قبل التاريخ ي
يقومون باحكام دقيق بانشاء صوره طبق الاصل
عن مكان مهدد بالاختفاء نهائيا كهف
كوسك قرب مدينه مارسيليا جنوب فرنسا
وبالضبط تحت مياه لكونك دو كاسيس يختبئ
موقع استثنائي كنز في اعماق البحر ظل في
معزل عن انظار الناس حتى عام
1985 خلال غوصه عثر اونري كوسك على خندق
ضيق بطول 150 مترا صعد فيه ليكتشف تجوي
ضخما كان شيئا عظيما وجميلا بالنسبه لي
بدات في التقاط الصور فرايت
حينها يدا
مرسومه شيئا فشيئا يتراءى امام نظريه كنز
اثري لا يقدر بثمن حوالي 200 رسم ضباء
وخيول وثيران وفقما وطيور وحيوانات كانت
موجوده في جنوب فرنسا خلال العصر الجليدي
قبل 27 الف سنه
بالنسبه للباحثين يعد هذا الاكتشاف
استثنائيا فتحليل هذه الرسومات يقدم
الكثير من المعلومات عن اسلاف من زمن غابر
لمده 14 الف عام دخل رجال ونساء واطفال
الى هذا التجويف لرسم مجموعه من الحيوانات
كالحصان والبيس والفقمه والبطريق كانوا
يرسمون حيوانات كانت تعيش الى جانبهم في
ساحل البحر الابيض المتوسط انذاك لكن
كانوا يقومون باشياء اخرى اكثر غموضا
اخ ما الحجر الج بكميات كبيره جدا الى
خارج الكهف دون معرفه السبب
بالضبط هذا الموقع الذي يحمل اسم مكتشفه
لا يزال حتى يومنا هذا الكهف المزخرف
الوحيد الذي بامكاننا الولوج اليه في قلب
مياه
البحر من غير المعقول ان نرى الى الان هذه
العلامه وهذه
التحيه ما هذا
لكن هذا الكنزه سيختفي للاسف بسبب ارتفاع
منسوب المياه بعد عده سنوات سيغرق الكهف
[موسيقى]
نهائيا نرى اختفاء ماده الرسم بسبب مياه
البحر الطريقه الوحيده للحفاظ على هذا
الارث تكمن في انشاء نسخه منه نسخه مثاليه
طبق الاصل بعيدا عن مياه المتوسط وبالضبط
في اقليم دوغدون يقوم فريق من المتخصصين
باعاده هيكله جذران كهف كوسك من دون اغفال
ايه تفاصيل حتى الدقيق
منها سنقوم تماما باعاده تشكيل جميع
الاشياء الدقيقه والشفافه في هذا
الك ا على راس فريق الفنانين هم من قاموا
باعاده تشكيل كهفي لاسكو وشوفي هذه المره
يستندون في عملهم على تصميمات ثلاثيه
الابعاد ويستخدمون تقنيات الواق الافتراضي
يستحيل عليهم الذهاب الى الكهف ف الولوج
اليه خطير جدا حاليا اود حقا الذهاب الى
الكهف فالتفاصيل الدقيقه ولمعان الرسومات
والاشياء غير الواضحه لا يمكن رؤيتها الا
هناك على ماده مستخدمه في صناعه البلاستيك
يقوم الفنانون بعرض صور الكهف الاصلي من
اجل اعاده تشكيل نسخه من
رسوماته العمل هنا على ما يرام ماد بعض
الشيء على الجهه
اليسرى لا يجب ان يكون اعتباطيا لابد ان
نفهم جيدا الطريقه التي اعتمدها الرسام
انذاك لابد ان نمعن النظر في حركات الرسم
لمعرفه ما اذا كان يرسم من اليسار الى
اليمين او العكس كما ينبغي ان نعرف قوه خط
الرسم وغيرها من الاشياء الواجب معرفتها
هل تغوصين في عقله احاول ذلك بعد اربعه
اعوام من العمل المضني تتجه المجسمات
الفنيه نحو مرسيليا وبالضبط الى هذا
المركز الثقافي حيث تاخذ به شكل الكهف
النهائي
الذي ابهر الجميع هنا من فنانين ورسامين
ونحاتين وغيرهم من
الزوار نحن نتمتع بالحركه الطفيفه للماء
على الجدار التي تخلق نوعا من الامواج
والاضاءه التي تجعل المكان اكثر
حيويه اف وراء بعضكم البعض من فضلكم مرحبا
ثلاث من فضلك ممتاز كما لو انهم ذهبوا
اليه فعلا صار بامكان الزوار بدء من عام
2022 اكتشاف كهف كوسك ضمن مساحه
1750 مترا مربعا وحوالي 500 نقش
ورسم انه جمال لا يوصف شعور جميل جدا نحن
نغوص في عوالم هذا الكهف كما لو اننا نعيش
اللحظات التي عاشها مكتشفو الكهف الحقيقي
انه امر ممتع لقد احببت رسوماتك كثرا
والحجاره التي تلمع لسنا في حاجه الى
معدات الغوص نحن نشعر وكاننا وسط الكهف
وجوده هنا داخل متحف مناسب جدا للصغار كما
الكبار اذا كان الكهف الحقيقي سيرق قريبا
في قاع البحر فان ارثه سيظل هنا على مراه
من الجميع في عام عرضها الاول استقطبت
النسخه المقلده لكهف كوسك 800 الف
زائر د